[Music]
what a fabulous event are you starstruck
are you cool I am starstruck I just saw
Camila and I know she was gonna be here
I was just mainly obsessing over the
fact that Ed Sheeran is here and then I
saw Camila and I'm a little dizzy and I
think I'm gonna throw up onstage
low-key now you are being honored with
the Rising Star Award what does that
mean for you seeing all these women come
up here tonight and say these beautiful
speeches with their awards is so
inspiring and really makes me realize
how blessed I am and I don't deserve
this at all
but I know people who do their butts off
for my dreams award
I do not deserve this they do the first
album just came out a few weeks ago so
how is that birthing that into the world
man it's been it's so motivating and
inspiring to kind of keep going
I'll have things change because it's
almost been a year well I mean I'm here
like what I just saw Camila Cabello
literally right there I listened to her
song I bana today like well oh it's
getting ready like that's absolutely
insane the what I'm feeling in my
stomach is like no other feeling I have
ever felt
right now
you
[Music]